[Music]
none why is there another ps+ video a
week after the last one well there is an
extra game which has been added to April
for all PlayStation Plus subscribers
call of duty black ops 4 blackout mode
before we get too excited please note
that this is a trial version of the
battle royale game-mode which released
about five months ago this is not the
standard version of black ops it's
solely the BR mode it's available right
the second right now but will be gone on
April 30th if you haven't seen any
blackout gameplay in a while I'll link
my video now but the greatest thing
about this PS Plus extra is the new map
freshly released this week Alcatraz the
brand spanking new area so if you jump
in right now you'll be on a level
playing field as everyone is learning
the new map just in case you've been
living under a rock you'll be jumping
from a plane sawing down to the ground
and murdering everyone you see as the
zone closes in around you
black ops is closer to pub G than fought
night with the first person perspective
used most of the time also weapon
attachments must be found on the field
giving blackout added depth at the
moment solo duo's and quads are
available so jump in while you can
April 30th this will be gone so what do
you think two PS plus adding monthly
trials do you think they should do it
more often
or should blackout be a free-to-play
game already let me know your thoughts
in the comments below I'm Adam from
Playstation grenade it's been short but
sweet I'll see you next time
[Music]